and they'll be going up against heremon
marquez a right-hander for the colorado
rockies this will be his 12th start of
the season 4.47
era right now 58 in the third innings
for him so far this season good
strikeouts though 62 strikeouts
1-2 on calhoun
and this ball in the air to center field
right at jonathan
he's got it and calhoun
is retired here's connor falefa marquez
originally property of tampa bay was
traded to colorado in 2016. now connor
falefa hits a fly ball to center an easy
play for dazak coming in
he's got this one and there are two fly
ball outs
and it brings up nate lowe hitting 249.
there's ball four and low
takes the walk mention that a moment ago
walks have been a problem for
marquez and here's adoles
ranger player of the month maybe will be
the league player of the month we'll
know tomorrow and he bounds the first
pitch on two hops to third base fuentes
guns it corner to corner he gets garcia
and the sides retired so uh the ranger
streak continues it's the 15th straight
game in which they have failed to score
in the first you know in this age of
everybody throws 6 000 miles an hour
especially when you think of a
first-round pick
he's not an overpowering guy that's a
hard shot but it's handled by connor
falefa and he gets topia by
a step i mean he'll work 90-91 that's it
he changes speeds well though especially
that change-up and the pitch is swung on
and rolled out short
another play for izzy he throws him out
and there are two outs
this ball driven to center field and
deep way back and
off the very top of the wall
and mack will hustle in a second with a
stand-up double
that went
415 feet it needs like another two feet
of elevation
he hit it on the line so well it turned
into his 12th double this year he is
going to hit it left center to right
center and he goes straight away right
near that right above that 415 sign
him trying to make it a scoreless bottom
of the first
and a hard ground ball that one hit the
umpire
and
i thought they played it live everybody
stopped running i think i think once it
gets past an infielder
then it's live but if it's in front of
an infielder
then it's a dead ball yeah that's what
happened it hit rapidly in the leg so
the
batter is credited with a hit chris
woodward comes out of the ranger dugout
the runner's not allowed to move up two
men aboard for charlie blackmon the hero
on sunday so here's charlie the man has
to stay at second and this is through
the left side base hit mcmahon cuts the
bag at third he'll score standing up one
nothing colorado stay hot charlie
blackman
clutch nasty comes through again charlie
blackman went up there with the idea of
hey guess what they threw changeups to
ryan mcmahon i'm going to look for
something soft and gets an rbi single
meanwhile the inning continues for
joshua fuentes
here's the pitch that one is lined to
center field garcia coming on he dives
and he makes the catch spectacular
diving backhand play by odolis garcia
to rob fuentes of a hit and a run batted
in that ends the first the rockies come
up with a run on three hits and they
leave two the outfield of coarse field
is huge
garcia's fantastic concentration
marquez gets a trevino ground out and
then dunning follows
with a safety right up the middle for
his first big league hit
dane dunning
yeah
get that ball
there you go he knows he knows the sign
absolutely get that baseball dane
dunning has not had an at-bat and we
don't know this for sure if anybody
asked him at least high school
that's the last because he didn't hit in
college
marquez kicks and delivers and a swing
and a miss and a good hard slider and
izzy strikes out so of course
through the first three innings the only
ranger to get a hit is dane dunning he's
stranded we'll go to the bottom of the
third rangers trailing one to nothing
tapia
hits the plate twice with his bat he's
almost facing dunning directly and then
closes up as the pitch comes in and this
one is pulled over first fielded by low
who races to the bag and gets there
ahead of tapia for the out tapia
grounded that one sharply right over
first base the o2 is punched toward the
right side and solace is right there
picks up the roller fires it over to low
in time to get krone for the final out
in the inning so no runs ahead so the
rangers have their first two men on here
in the top of the fourth trailing one to
nothing and joey gallo stepping to the
plate joey was called out on strikes in
the second the 2-1 pitch
pulled on the right side this is crone
who's up with it goes to second for one
back to first and the ball gets by
marquez it stays in foul ground racing
down the line from third is nate lowe he
scored so garcia is out on the play 3-6
but on a throwing error by the shortstop
brendan rodgers passed marquez covering
it first low is able to score from
second on the play and we're tied at one
rocky's trying to come through now with
two outs after the lead off double dasa
finds himself in a two-strike hole
dunning's pitch
lined up the middle and into center
field for a base hit
nunez will score
jonathan dazzo with a two out bullet up
the middle rocky's regain the lead two
to one yeah right near his glove as he
tried to snag it medaza with a hit with
runners in scoring position or a runner
in scoring position and two outs
so king trying to keep this a one-run
game as we play here in the bottom of
the sixth inning the pitch swing and a
miss got him on a slider that ends the
inning no runs a hit two men left after
six it's still two to one rockets trying
to avoid walking gallow to begin this
seventh 3-2 pitch swing and a miss
got him on a breaking ball
out number one strikeout number six for
marcus 3-2 pitch from marquez that one
is hit down the third base line to
fuentes long throw in time to get solac
gloved it near the line and gunned him
out in another good play by fuentes gets
down there and now from there he doesn't
stand up to make the throw he uses the
legs to help him throw two to one rocky
shift on for this left-hand batter and
the pitch is a cold strike three
and he got brockholt who tosses the bat
away and the helmet two here comes chris
davis still looking for his first
rangers home run he has 218 career long
balls
and there's a high drive hit deep to
right field this one's way back and that
ball is history
chris davis has tied the game with his
first home run as a ranger clearing the
16 foot high wall in right career home
run number 219
and we're tied at two so gallow gets
over to third and the count goes to two
and two in the pitch to heim swing and a
miss
big strikeout for tyler kinley to strand
gallow at third in the top of the tent
so charlie didn't get the hit but put it
in play so that you could get that
winning run 90 feet closer
ball gets away here comes mcmahon
safe at the plate and the rockies win it
on a wild pitch
colorado walks off the rangers